if you wanted to destroy a city's
housing short of bombing probably the
best way to do it is rent control
rent control is this New York is Times
Square she pays less than a studio how
is that possible she's lived here over
40 years rent controls a beautiful thing
celebrities like Mia Farrow Cyndi Lauper
Edie Koch and Charlie Rangel have
benefited from either rent control or
rent stabilization two sets of laws that
keep half of New York City's rents
artificially low it's not a cliche to
say it's a textbook example of bad
economic policy results are exactly
opposite of the intended it was not
supplying houses to low-income people it
was not it was lowering the supply of
houses it was lowering the quality of
houses kaito legal associate Trevor
Burrus wrote a brief on Hartmann V
Kimmel a new case that could actually
bring an end to rent control the
Hartmann cases challenging rent control
in New York City
mr. Hartmann he is both the lawyer and
the plaintiff in this case he owns a
building on the Upper West Side which
has been occupied for combined total of
90 years by tenants and subsequent
tenants at a rate 59 percent below the
market value he petitioned the Supreme
Court to hear the case they sought
enough merit in the arguments but they
wanted to hear the other side of the
argument and so that's where the case
stands right now maybe not on the cusp
of the Supreme Court but far closer than
many people would have guessed it could
of god there is a takings clause in the
US Constitution and the fifth fifth
amendment that prohibits the taking of
property for either public use and with
just compensation we can get the court
to see that we could possibly overturn
rent control rent control has been doing
damage to New York since the 1940s one
thing most people are agreed on is the
rent control is a good thing no
justification can exist for this law
anymore it doesn't meet their own
standards of why they passed the law
unfortunately it has a powerful interest
group the more than a million New
Yorkers with artificially cheap rents
it's a perfect example of what
economists like to call concentrated
benefits and dispersed costs because the
benefits accrue very specifically to a
specific group of people who will vote
and fight to keep those benefits the
costs they build up over time they're
hard to point to it's hard to give a
good what if this didn't happen story
with this apartment building still be
standing because the landlord had enough
money from rince the legislature doesn't
see
be totally listening because they renew
this all the time but maybe the courts
can listen to this maybe they will be
listening